so today I wanted to talk about a
lobster which is a new package that I've
been working on as part of the second
edition of advance star so one of the
big changes in this next edition is
there's a bunch more diagrams because I
think they really help you understand
what's going on with our and of course
then in the book there's like a bunch of
like diagrams that I spend like hours
drawing by hand which are great for the
stuff that's in the book but then how do
you go and then apply how do you use
those same ideas with your own code so
today I'm going to show you some the
tools of the lobster that basically
tools for creating command line
visualizations of kind of interesting
things in the our language interesting
and challenging things about the our
language so we're going to talk about
three big ideas today the distinction
between names and values in our with the
riff function the fact that in our code
all our code you can think of as a tree
with the ast function and then finally
we'll talk a little bit about some of
the sort of something I just recently
came to understand about trace backs or
call stacks and are and how they're not
actually just a linear stack they're
actually a tree and I think that's gonna
have some profound implications for
making more useful error messages in are
now Lobster is still only on github but
you know I am serious about it because
it has a logo and just the logo
hopefully makes it obvious that the
inspiration for the name is these are
kind of functions like the STR function
and bass are so STR displays the
structure of any our object and kind of
a tree like fashion all of the functions
and lobst or many of the functions are
Lobster try and do a save the similar
thing like create a little visualization
and all the console tree that describes
some kind of object in half in most of
all at least for the first two topics
these correspond to chapters and the
advanced are I'll put these links up
again at the end but if you want to
learn more about any of these topics you
can go and read the chapters in advance
stuff but I'm gonna start with a little
quiz for you all so I want you to run
this our code and you're here I've run
the first
I've created a victor with a million
random normal at random uniforms and I
found out its size which is about eight
megabytes so what I want you to do now
is run the rest of the code in your head
and see what it outputs and then like
talk it over with your neighbor see if
you've got get to the same answer or not
see what do you you've got one minute to
run this code starting now
okay times up so let's do it just a
quick show of hands how many predicted
that the answer for this was gonna be
about 24 megabytes and and how many
people thought well I think it probably
is 24 megabytes but if the answer was so
simple Headley wouldn't have like tried
to trick me like this yeah so if we
actually let's - let's run this code in
our and Jared Todd me is extremely
dangerous to run our code live and a
talk but I'm gonna do it anyway so just
to verify this a million random uniforms
that's a a uniform in ours a double a
double takes up eight bytes so we've got
a million of them so it's about eight
million bytes plus a little bit which
I'm not going to talk about today and
actually we're no we're not gonna run
that uh I guess I I'm gonna copy and
paste if I run this it's actually just
it's still eight megabytes and a little
bit we'll see why that is very shortly
and then what happens if I modify one of
the values in that list well now all of
a sudden it's now sixteen megabytes so
what the heck is going on here it's
easiest to understand with some pictures
and to kind of understand what the
assignment arrow is actually doing your
Simon arrow is not creating an object
the VI unit function is creating the
object what the assignment arrow is
doing is associating this object or this
value with a name and this is like
analysis are basically like a reference
it's kind of like a pointer I'm not
gonna use pointer because that kind of
conveys some like specific technical
meaning which is not true now but it's
like a reference to name references
about you in fact like many references
can point to one object so when you
assign one object to another object or
that's not really what you're doing
right when you use the assignment area
multiple times you're actually just
referencing the same value from multiple
names so now when you if you've done
this an hour like now you can kind of
ask this question well how big is a well
a is going to be the
sizes six right is about eight megabytes
how bigger a and B together well kind of
strangely but they're both eight
megabytes right to the size of two
references and are like the size of a
and the size of B together does not
equal the size of a plus the size of B
so this kind of like non transitivity
makes reasoning about how big an object
is in are quite challenging and we can
kind of verify that with some our code
so one thing the object object
underscore size function which comes
from Lobster does you can give up
multiple objects and it tells you the
total size of those objects so you can
see a and B individually eight megabytes
and not also add megabytes together
before I go and should I make anyone
read this code okay or I need to make a
little bigger make a little bigger
that's about that's about as big as I
can go and you can still actually see
what I'm doing okay so you can have
multiple names pointing or referencing
the same value and that's also true of
lists so when you create a list are does
not copy all of the things into that
list it just references them where they
lie so now when we say well how big is X
well that's about eight megabytes
how big is why that's also about eight
megabytes so let's make that a little
bit more precise hopefully if I remember
the order and this is what we're
supposed to do this so if we look at the
size of Y minus the size of X we can see
that's 72 bytes and kind of
interestingly that's exactly the same
size as a list a list of three empty
elements so the size of that list is the
size of X plus the size of a list and
the size of a list is basically a bunch
of pointers and this kind of like if you
like a pointer you might happen to know
is like eight bytes and so three times
eight is 20 meter right that's leaning
me a bad direction
cuz that's not gonna work out I uh let's
get back to this oops
you'll noticed is like a little bit of
over here on our objects because they
have to store some kind of other
information which is about 40 bytes and
I can't remember exactly why it's not
ending up forty watts there okay so we
also have another tool oops
let's just rerun this so you know you
don't have me to draw all these diagrams
for you by hand when you're trying to
understand what's going on with your
objects so Lobster comes with as riff
function and what a riff attempts to do
is tell you like the structure of your
object and how it like references other
objects so you can see here we have a
list and each object in our has this
kind of each value in our has this sort
of identified there's a dress and this
is basically where that object lives in
memory which is doesn't really mean
anything because every time you start
it's gonna occupy a different part of
memory on your computer but within a
session this allows us to kind of
identify a value rather than a name and
so we can see here we have this list its
name its its addresses I'm not gonna say
the whole thing but its 0x 7b if cetera
and then inside this list we have a
double which is this address and then
the other components of the list are
just that same object repeated again so
you can see as well as the address
there's also this kind of local address
so you can see that this is the object
too and these other two elements of the
list point back to that object so what
happens when you modify an object in the
list well an are modifying an object
creates a copy so this sort of happens
in two steps so if I'm going to modify
the first element of Y well first of all
I was going to create the X modified to
what the first value changed and then
it's basically going to change with
references so now if we asked like how
big is X Y Lakes is still about 8
megabytes this victor is about 8
megabytes and so the size of Y is gonna
be this Victor Plus this victor plus a
little bit of accounting over here
so it's giving about 16 gigabytes and so
what happens if we modify X well the
same things going to happen I was going
to create a new victor that is modified
and then it's going to change we X
points too so kind of all the time like
we never Uther almost always whenever
you think you're modifying something a
now you're actually modifying a copy
with one little exception which I'll get
to shortly now what happens when you if
you want to remove these objects well an
R you can call our in and what our in
does is removes the names it removes the
references to those values RM doesn't
actually delete the object or the values
themselves so that's the job of the
garbage collector and what the garbage
collector does is every so often like
either when you need more memory or just
every so many kind of victor creations I
was going to go through and look for all
of the objects that have no references
pointing to them and it's going to clear
them out so you can use that memory
again so in this case it's going to look
through it's going to find while there's
two objects that nothing points to this
victor at the top and this list down the
bottom and it's going to delete those
and then it's going to realize well now
there's two new Victor's that I have
everything pointing to them and it's
going to get rid of those as well so
when you remove an object in our at
capital happens and two passes first you
remove the remove the references and
then later on kind of stochastically the
garbage collectors going to come along
and actually delete those objects and
free up the memory for you but there's
kind of one exception to this rule
because if every time you modified an
object in our it created a copy I would
be like incredibly slow like ours not
like a fast language as it is but have
had to create a new victor copy every
single time he modifies something would
be astronomically slow so like if if you
had a victor like this
and you modified it and you modified it
again right this you end up with you
don't end up with three copies of that
Viktor so R has this optimization so
that if it knows that the Viktor only
has one name it only has one reference
pointing to it it will modify it in
place so this kind of keeps the
performance of our at like sort of a
reasonable level it has the special
optimization because if only one thing
is pointing to an object like it doesn't
really matter if you modify it in place
on the outside view outside world it's
exactly the same as if you had created a
copy and then change the reference to it
because there's only that one reference
and we can kind of one way to do that in
to see what's going on which I'm going
to briefly do something crazy and I'm
gonna use the terminal pane in our
studio and I am gonna run our inside of
that for a reason which I'm going to
explain shortly now this is like a
little bit this a little bit this is a
little bit insane and you can do some
there's this really old dev tools
function called dev tools what do they
call it yeah oh it's I'm not inside of a
package it said but you can't actually
use dev tools to quote bash which will
open a bash shell inside this and you
can call our inside that and it gets
very confusing actually I think you can
just do this how's this gonna work yeah
so now I'm running bash I'm running our
inside our studios Tamriel inside that
I'm running bash and then inside that I
can run off
that's that's a really bad idea there so
I'm not gonna do it
okay so Becca nah I'm gonna create a
victor I'm gonna call tres min and what
this does is it just prints out the
address of that object and now whenever
that object gets copied it is going to
print out something like this that that
object just got copied oops and I
accidentally used the wrong keyboard
shortcut so I'm gonna run this in my our
terminal and you see when I'm modifying
that victor no copies are occurring
because there's only one thing pointing
to it if I did this I'm gonna keep using
the wrong keyboard shortcut if I did
this so there's now two of these now two
names pointing to that same victor if I
change it it's gonna have to create a
copy and it only has to do that once
right because now there is only one
thing pointing to that new object now
unfortunately if you run the same code
in our studio you will get confused
because it looks like when you're
modifying it it's actually creating a
copy well it is actually creating a copy
and that's because of one really helpful
feature in our studio which is the
environment pane and so the environment
pane creates like another reference to
this object so that when you're
experimenting with us interactively in
our studio it's always going to create a
copy now you might wonder like is this
gonna make a studio make all of my code
catastrophic lis slow no because most of
the time you're not like doing a bunch
of modifications at the top level that's
inside a function or inside a for loop
and a skew doesn't see that object it
doesn't put in the environment pane so
it's not it's not a big deal
okay so tres Miam allows you to see
whenever an object gets copied and
because of the rules for like wind so
that this is all this the seem
straightforward but the big complication
is that when our is kind of counting how
many references are pointing to an
object it can only count up to two two
basically so it knows if there are zero
references one reference or if there are
many references so that means if you
have like three references to an object
and you delete two of them
I cannot kind of figure out that there's
only one left so maybe that might happen
in a future version of our but that
basically means like it's very difficult
for you to predict when a copy will
occur or not so if you're ever wondering
if you're ever trying to optimize
performance of this level like use trace
meme don't try and think it through just
see exactly what happens okay so it's
kind of the first big idea that there's
an in are there's this really important
distinction between names and values you
might think that assignment or calling a
function is going to copy your vector
that's not going to be the case the
objects and our only copied when you
modify them the next thing I want to
talk about is this kind of powerful idea
that makes it really easy to write our
code that writes our code and that's
this idea that an are all code is a tree
and what do I mean by that I mean
basically you can draw any our
expression in a tree like this I'm gonna
draw this function call as an orange
square and then the first child is the
name of the function that's called and
in the subsequent the subsequent
children are the arguments to that
function X the letter Y and the number
one and no matter how complicated your
our code is you can always draw it in
this form as this tree like structure
there's one little wrinkle though
because here I've drawn this this is
kind of the type of code you call with
the functions that you have written in
our this is called a prefix function
call because the name of the function
comes first before its arguments but
there are other function calls in our
that are not there do not look like
there
so a very common class of those calls
are called in fix function calls where
the name of the function comes in
between its arguments so two two
comments you used functions that are in
fixed functions the assignment arrow the
thing that's being assigned to is on the
Left it's the value that's being
assigned is on the right and
multiplication like the this is the
multiplication function comes in between
its arguments and it turns out and I you
can rewrite any function call and are no
matter how weird it looks in this prefix
form where the name of the function
comes first
now if the name of the function is
something weird like a Simon arrow or
multiplication here they're putting it
between backticks
but you can rewrite any our expression
in this way and so again you can just
read this tree like we did before we've
got two function calls the first
function call is the assignment arrow
it's going to assign the reference Y to
the value which is the result of
computing X times y so let's have a look
at that so just like with riff
the the first example there is a
function and lobster which helps you
draw these diagrams called ast it's
called a AST because in computer science
the name for these trees is abstract
syntax trees now every single
programming language has an abstract
syntax tree but as unusual in the cross
programming languages to be able to
access that tree directly but you can't
an R which makes it pretty neat so here
I'm just going to show you the AB the
ast output for that first function and
it just tries to try to draw that tree
as closely as it can and the console you
can see that orange squares the function
call the first argument is the function
being the first child as the function
being called then we have the arguments
X the little Y and the number one and no
matter how complicated there gets let's
make it a little bit more complicated
oops now I've got too many parentheses
it'll just draw that tree for you it'll
also draw it for you you know you never
knew when you've got expressions that do
not immediately look like they're in
this form that the way the name of the
function is not the first thing so this
kind of allows us to like dig in a
little bit that how ours grammar works
so like when you add two numbers
together the plus function takes two
arguments so there's kind of two ways
that our might interpret this right it
could do one plus two and then add on
three or it could do one plus two plus
three and now this doesn't matter most
of the time right because it doesn't
matter for addition it doesn't matter
which order you do it in but this is
like really important for packages where
addition no longer has this property so
for example in ggplot2 we use plus the
order in which you do the addition is
actually really important and there's
one reason why the plus is not a great
fit for GT Pro - that's a different
question that's a different talk so when
we when we print this with AST you can
see there's a function quarter plus the
first argument to that is another
quarter plus which is one plus two so
this is the way you describe this as R
as lifts associative because it does the
things on the Left first the only
exception to that is like exponentiation
which is right associative it does the
things on the right first and it allows
us to see kind of other quirks of our
like if you do not x and y that is not
going to do not X and then see if that's
and why it's going to do is x and y and
then take the opposite of that this I
thing is kind of one reason that there
isn't like a built in like some people
like one not in I guess you could do I
don't know I hate it right some people
do something like this
well then you're just right like this
seems kind of pointless it also allows
us to see to dig into like other things
and in our that look even less like
function calls and multiplication and
assignment like so what about an if
statement how was that a function well
we can ask ast to draw that and it turns
out the quarter F is a function with
three arguments the first argument is
the condition the second argument is
what the return of the condition is true
and the third argument is what the
return of the condition is false well
similarly like one of the arguments to
the four function well the arguments the
four function are the name of the thing
that you're indexing over the the value
of the thing that you're indexing over
and in the body of the for loop or like
what is the function function what does
that do well the function function is a
function with three arguments so the
first argument is the arguments the
function the second argument is the body
of the function and the third argument
is the source riff which is the text of
the function and that's what enables you
when you print out a function you see
though all the comments and stuff inside
the function those are not normally
captured by the abstract syntax tree
because they're not syntax that's just
human readable stuff the ast just
captures stuff that our key is about so
so why should you care about this I
think one reason is this is an important
part of Tidy evaluation so tidy
evaluation is a toolkit that allows you
to program with packages like ggplot2
and d plier and it's powered by the R
Lang function our Lang package one of
the cool functions and the R Lang
package is this extra Peck extra
function what that does is it basically
captures what you give it it just
returns exactly the code that you gave
it but it also support I'm quoting with
this crazy bang bang operator so the
bang bang is called the uncoding
operator it's pronounced bang bang
obviously as a
said like five times now but what it
does is easiest to see when once you
understand the code as a tree it's
really easy to draw what bang-bang does
so what Peng Peng does is we have one
code tree here and one code tree here
the bangbang kind of defines like a hole
which we just insert that other tree
into so bangbang allows us to build up
complex trees from simple pieces so I've
explained that very very quickly and now
I'm going to give you all the challenge
to see if you can run this our code in
your head so see if you can figure out
predict what this is going to return
based on that extremely quick
description you have one minute starting
now
okay times up so what is this first call
gonna return just going to be X plus y
right because the expert just captures
what you gave it what about the second
one it should be pretty easy to
hopefully write X plus y plus Z you've
combined that first expression with the
second one what about the last one this
is a little challenging right because it
could return 1 over X 1 over X plus y or
1 over X plus y right it's hard to say
it's easier to show but it does actually
return the second one because we're
dealing with these trees those
parentheses kind of get inserted
automatically and and correctly and this
is kind of one of the reasons why I
think thinking about trees when you're
creating code in this way it's much
better than thinking about strings and
pasting strings together like an animal
because it preserves this important tree
like structure of the code so that's
another important aspect of our like you
can represent all code as a tree and the
thing that makes the every language does
that the thing that makes our special is
you can actually like capture that tree
it's a first-class type of object and
now you can capture that tree and you
can work with it and that's what powers
like that's what allows deep liar to
take your our code and translate that
into sequel because inside DB ply and
actually like computes on the tree of
our code and translates that to
something else this is sort of to me
like one of the reasons like it doesn't
actually matter that our is kind of
relatively slow compared to other
programming languages because I doesn't
have to be fast it just makes friends
with other environments and you can
easily translate our code to those other
environments the one last thing I wanted
to talk about is something I only
discovered very recently just this idea
that call stacks or trace backs are not
actually stacks they're actually trees
so the kind of motivation is sort of
like is this basically so
I've created some function some victor
eyes function that I'm going to use with
ggplot2 and like deep in the bowels of
that function there's an error and now
when I use this inside ggplot2 and I
print out the trace back it's kind of
hard to see like where my coders and
where ggplot2 coders like it's hard to
see like where is that where's the
source of that problem like the the bit
I actually care about is kind of like my
code the if called G equal eight and in
that caused an error now I kind of
wanted to show you like what that would
look like with my proposed tools but
unfortunately it just this revealed a
bug in the way that works so we're going
to kind of work our way up with some
simple examples so it lobster provides
the CST function that stands for call
stack tree basically and so this is kind
of equivalent to trace back but what's
gonna do is it's gonna display this in a
tree like way and for a simple function
call like this you know if cause JG
calls HHH calls the CST function you
just see that as like a tree with one
set of one branch basically if we every
tree only has one child so when there's
when when everything is eagerly
evaluated it's really simple things get
more complicated when you start using
functions that kind of let the worth
we're lazy evaluation comes in so I'm
going to use the identity function
before I will claim I think the identity
function is the simplest function in
base are you give it an argument X and
it simply returns that argument right
there's there's nothing well there's
almost nothing simpler that a function
could do but what this is what this is
going to cause is this this is gonna be
like lazily evaluated right because in
our function arguments are only
evaluated women when they're needed in
which case this case is needed right
away but it adds some kind of
complication to that call stack tree so
I'm going to call identity identity if
and see what happens
and now we actually get this tree like
structure so we see identity calls and
the evaluation of this is only kind of
going to be triggered inside this
function so we get a new branch and then
we see our code at the end and like when
you start mixing like tries into the
putting tries and the mix things start
to get more and more complicated and if
you've ever tried to debug a code that's
inside a try-catch you'll have noticed
like the trace pack includes all of
these weird parts these are these
details about how try-catch is
implemented that you are not you do not
actually care about because they're not
in your code and this tree like
structure makes it very easy to say well
the thing that you're actually
interested in is always like the
terminal branch of this tree and so my
hope is like with this understanding
this will allow us to make much much
simpler call stack much much more useful
trace back messages in our studio and
under tidy vests and I wanted to kind of
like one illustrate like one extreme
aspect of that and this is a call stack
generated from inside shiny which so if
you've ever tried to debug like shiny
card shiny its code is challenging to
debug because your code is embedded in
this much bigger framework for like
handling when your code should be
evaluated and if you like a look at the
full trace back and this is drawn as a
tree which makes it even which makes it
like at least feasible to understand but
you'll see like it's quite complicated
right like if there's like we're still
like going this still isn't even at my
my code yet we're still going and this
is actually the bit that you care about
like inside the rend up the render plot
you've called is the stop function this
is arrow that's that this bit is what
you actually care about this is the bit
of your code that is important not the
rest of the shinies infrastructure to
run your code and that's really when
you're just looking at the stack trace
linearly it's really hard to identify
that this ism this is the important bit
but it turns out like
once you display it as a tree and think
about as a tree it's like really easy to
say now well in this case it's kind of a
stick and bright it's the second
terminal branch from the end and we can
hopefully in a future version of shiny
well I drill down and when you have an
error message you will see your era that
your code that caused the air and not
all of the infrastructure and shiny has
already done a bunch of work which is
this kind of stack trace on stuff which
to try and kind of make the stack trace
a little bit more manageable but there's
sort of realization that this the stack
trace is actually a tree I think it's
gonna help profoundly like throughout
the tidy verse throughout in our studio
and shiny make error messages much much
of the trace backs more informative so
you can see exactly where the problem
lies not what is all the other code
that's run your code that's eventually
caused the error so to sum up I've kind
of shown you how that's a terrible
showing you learn three planets me fix
that okay so I have shown you three big
ideas that the previous title was I you
have learned three big ideas but I
thought that might be a little
aggressive given that I just showed them
to you very briefly but I have
definitely shown you three ideas I'm not
going to make any assertions about
whether you have understood them or
learned them or not but I think three
big ideas and this is not even in the
order in which I presented them
see my process live here it spent so
much time learning is perfectly up so
three big ideas the first big idea I
think is the most important that like if
you can kind of separate the idea of
names or references from objects or
values you will be able to build up a
much more accurate mental model of like
what operations are going to be
expensive in your R code and by and
large the things that are expensive are
modifying objects not passing them to
functions or putting them on lists so if
you want to understand that a more
detail that that's the ref function in
lobster which prints out kind of the
first time you see each value in an
object in a list or a set of lists or
set of objects and then shows you that
you're not actually copying things
you're just pointing to them or
referencing them the next big idea isn't
that R and is that all our code is a
tree so our code forms this thing called
the abstract syntax tree or a a steeper
short you can display that with the
lobster ast function and that is
anything important to kind of understand
that basic idea if you want to use tidy
evaluation because that's what allows
you to safely insert your variable or
your expression and the big more
complicated expressions preserving
correct operator precedence and so on
it's also what allows me to create tools
like DB plier which lets you translate
our code to sequel code and finally it
took a little bit about this idea that
call stacks are trees I think that's
going to be kind of like most important
for like me and other developers at our
studio because we can use this to create
you know better more informative tre
specs when you hit in the other so
altogether I think these the these three
things are three things that make are a
little bit different to other
programming languages there are very few
other programming languages that wow
there's so some programming do make this
distinction between names and values and
other
do allow you to access code as a tree
and very few programming languages have
lazy evaluation but the combination of
these three things I think like makes
are special to me and that that's like
one of the things like I don't like I
personally get a huge amount of
satisfaction about learning this sort of
stuff about the our language and to me
like you know a lot of people look at
our and they like if they've experience
with other programming languages maybe
like they throw up a little bit in their
mouth because our is legitimately
different to other programming languages
but to me that that difference is
unambiguously a strength not a weakness
and sure many of these features do
actually make are like they kind of
fundamentally limit the computational
performance of our they mean that our is
never gonna be like as fast as Python or
as fast as C++ but they also mean that
that distinction is not actually that
important like our is a language that is
optimized for human performance not
computer performance and when you are
working with larger datasets
particularly the second features a huge
strength because you just leave your
data where it is you leave data in a
system that is designed specifically for
working with large data sets in the
high-performance way and then you write
our code and an R package translates
your R code or whatever that other
system might understand and so you get
the seamless workflow where you can do
very rapid exploration of in-memory data
with our and then when you need to scale
up you talk to some other specialized
system thank you
[Applause]
you